grad several swinter Vento bravura
frontal to teatime in the agenda rupiah
destro de la parola presidente from the
lion hearing great Cerberus represents
in ala prego president thank you very
much mr. president
honourable members it's such a pleasure
prime minister to see you again at the
start of the Croatian presidency it's
just a few days ago that the College of
Commissioners were treated to the very
famous and outstanding finest Croatian
hospitality we spent wonderful 24 hours
we saw some of the very rich culture
traditional folklore diversity all that
what Croatia has brought to the Union it
was a phenomenal ceremony at the opening
of the presidency in the National
Theatre which showed the energy and the
enthusiasm Croatia brings to the Union
so thank you very much for that and it's
also a very special moment to sit here
and to listen to the prime minister
speak about the president see here in
the home of the European democracy
because I know Andre that this house is
a place that is very dear to your heart
and there are not many who can say that
they have been a European Parliament
trainee then later on an MEP and then
have come back to Strasbourg as a prime
minister
chairing the EU presidency chapeau and
respect to that
and in some ways it always your story
mirrors the remarkable journey your
country has been taken as you've just
said in the space of only three decades
Croatia has gone from bitter bloodshed
to being here today at the beating heart
of our union
tomorrow you will celebrate the day of
international recognition marking 28
years since the European community
recognized Croatia but no one could have
imagined then how far and how fast this
country has grown that is down to the
will of your people to the sacrifice
they made to the commitment to European
values and to their determination to
join our union of peace progress and
prosperity and over the next six months
we'll need all that determination that
unity and energy that Croatians are
famous for we will need that
determination to find common solutions
to issues that have divided us in the
past like for example migration will be
one of the tasks will we be tackling we
will need that unity to handle brexit
and budget negotiations and deal with
the pressing international issues you
just mentioned and we will need that
energy to ensure that Europe can shape
the digital and climate transitions this
is the task ahead of us and I'm the like
delighted that the Croatian presidency
reflects this fully in the four pillars
the Prime Minister was just mentioning
the presidencies motto says we need a
strong Europe in a world of challenges
and indeed it's true that the challenges
around us are becoming louder and more
dangerous and more intensive by the day
and I think it's now for the
constructive force to help push back on
the world's destructive tendencies and
it's always the same as long as there's
violence out it's very loud and dominant
but the violence only ends if the talks
start again and here is the strength of
the European Union because the European
Union has an enormous amount of
diplomatic strength is able to focus on
the escalation dialogue because we have
a good relation to many many actors in
that region and partners in the region
we have relations that are time-tested
relations that are reliable that are
trusted we've played an enormous role
and still do play in the stabilization
of Iraq and the same goes for brokering
the nuclear agreement with Iran but
beyond conflict resolution
now it's also at the time for you to be
more assertive on the global stage
to strengthen our position as the
trading power of the world to deepen as
you've set our relationship to NATO and
take more responsibility on ourselves to
build an alliance with Africa that can
stand the test of time and help boost
both of our economies we will have the
college to college meeting with Africa
and will be preparation preparing the
African summit and in this spirit will
present also our comprehensive strategy
with Africa during your presidency the
next six months will be crucial for our
relationship with the Balkans you
mentioned it Andrae Croatia knows better
than most the power of European
perspective it's a matter of perspective
to have it a true perspective and
Croatia knows better than most how far
it can take countries in transforming
their systems and economies pressure
knows the good
Europe can do by engaging and investing
in the region it is now particularly
important that we keep up this momentum
before the zaccharas summit on the
Western Balkan later this year if we
want the Western
welcome summit in Zagreb to be a success
we have to do our homework No
now that's a reason why we will put
forward our enlargement methodology in a
few weeks so that we can discuss the
modernization that is necessary but the
most important part is to give our
friends and the Western Balkan a
perspective for beginning the ASEC as
accession talks with North Macedonia
with Albania
they've done their homework we've asked
them to do so it's time to give them a
real perspective perspective to move on
now the leadership will also be
essential of Croatia when it comes to
negotiations of our future budget over
the next weeks the presidency supported
by President Michel will look to make
headway so we can reach an agreement we
need a balanced budget yes we need a
fair budget yes but we most of all need
a modern budget the next seven years are
different from the seven years we've
gone through so it is of utmost
importance that the modernization part
that's what people expect us to do
that's where all the Member States keep
asking the European Union to move
forward to be active to be visible so if
we want to deliver on these topics we
need a decent budget in the
modernization and thank you for fighting
for that this is crucial for us madam
Jamis really deep ET le Sima de la
president squat so Egon Mauricio Pereyra
transition climatic a ecologic Univ on
pre besoin de peraleda regions on
kanessa a del obligación de jia not even
passing mad no election we met on
Nirvana trip active air pulip let's have
a coma so shall we
ELISA de sediba local a discreet ha de
plan Davi gavest is more polar pact
we're able mechanism upon transition
rooster Alexa Nouveau mechanism
Donovan a priority sector a origin key
zone confront a program defeat a kid
wafu near dupree groans fr-s a cassette
upon a poor Tom Pollock OSE beaucoup
daughter de le propositions on top of a
particular levies president ma man's
Dombrowski's some OTC on plein air Papa
presently to lead a tie
Shakuntala President Scott provinces
owes him a to Sookie sweet home
Donna seemed an alum wha a venir Manny
de menthe hang up coordinator it mr. ups
listen meet involving an artisan Church
Delavan the as Estefan professional
journalist in in karate and Varma Diaz
agaaca see sweep I Malvo einheit East is
high height entice Russian Amazonia
Hoopa both einheit keep on the OL
patience on the height is that says five
Villiger einheit East was einheit keep
dougie plus Phi height under give us our
craft expend our phone about sarcastic
Oh our to show president shaft in a
presidential that Ironhide sign but I in
a presidential - Talca for a rope a sign
but in a presidential tion institution
for unwilling vote by the mouth pal Vee
resonant in oil and presidential motto
inertia tell Canopus in our house
foreign invader danke Schoen gratia
gratia Presidente
[Applause]